[Music]
I'm mr. Hein and we're going to talk
about how to eat this week so how do you
is a blanket term that means literally
belly power how is it comes from the
belly it generally is referring to
alignments making good alignments with
the body and using the body in a way
that that makes you seem very powerful
when we look at these concepts we can
look at them like tricks so we can look
at them as if they were just little
trivial tricks that can be done then
impress people
or we can look at them as concepts and
important principles that we can use for
our egg into practice so these are good
ways to make alignment that are very
very useful in Aikido so I'm gonna bring
in a couple of people here and we're
gonna see what we can show you first one
we're to talk about is alignment
okay so we have sake here injunction and
we're gonna use them soft is about five
foot tall probably weighs right around
100 pounds so telling you that you know
she's not a ferocious physical creature
right so she's not amazingly strong and
she didn't wrestle all through school
and she's strong and very capable with
their body but she's not you know some
kind of beasts monster person and we
didn't hike weights in her pants or
anything to trick you guys so the first
thing we're talking about is alignment
we were making good alignments you want
to make the strongest alignment you can
with your body in the ground so right
now in this natural position Sascha's
and a pretty strong alignment in fact if
Josh were to come up behind her and just
jump up in the air and land behind her
like this she can pretty easily one of
them right there like that right so and
all the tapping loss is less she's not
having to use a whole lot of muscles
other than take deeper core from coming
out of alignment all she's doing is
allowing that force to go through her
bones and into the ground another way
stop she can do that she can align up
horizontally to Josh so we had Josh come
over here Sasha reaches out into Josh
okay so if josh is reaching a grabbing
Sasha and reaching out into our net
sasha reaches back into Josh she can
make an alignment from our foot all the
way through the structure foreboding
into Josh giving Josh a lot of
difficulty now josh is bigger and
stronger than Sasha but Sasha's able you
can relax but the staple the whole
the back break and the reason is cuz she
has her bones aligned in a really nice
way another way we can show this his job
that Sasha could sit on the ground
and Josh could push on to her chest and
what's us gonna do again is she's gonna
make an alignment to align with Josh so
as he's pushing into her she's able to
keep him back by aligning her body and
the same thing that's famously
demonstrated by you is she was he can
push on her head and she lying again and
all she's doing here is making a
straight line through all the muscles
are bums in her body and straight
through the ground giving them a lot of
difficulty in holding or pushing her
over this is the alignment principle and
the first important thing we need to
understand we're talking about huh TV
and Aikido